the science and religion both have very
particular ideas about how the world
works ideas that potentially are not
totally compatible but that are
overlapping science claims to be a
system that can discover absolutely
anything that is totally comprehensive
religion also claims a comprehensiveness
that is based in reality where God
whatever that deity may be is absolutely
real maybe even more real than anything
or anyone else so I got to thinking that
perhaps these two systems needed to find
a way to talk to each other or at least
to cross paths and to do that I took as
the basis of a sort of a thought
experiment central beliefs from each of
the two systems that seemed on the
surface to be completely incompatible
namely I took God to be as literally
real as you and I as a building a dog a
cat anything else and I took science at
its word that it could learn everything
about everything about anything that
that was real anything that had any
substance in the world to do that I
decided that I would attempt to
scientifically figure out where on the
phylogenetic tree which is the master
map of all the species on earth where
you might put god what species is God
that was a question that I asked myself
and then I had to find a way to address
it scientifically so science has many
different ways in which you can pursue
such a question probably the most
obvious would be to obtain DNA for God
but I couldn't get my hands on that so
another possibility I realized was to
attempt to genetically engineer God in a
laboratory and so I found collaborators
at UC Berkeley and several other
institutions who are willing to help me
through that process using something
known as continuous in vitro evolution
which essentially is an accelerated and
directed version of natural selection in
which you apply environmental pressures
on a given population of an organism in
such a way that you favor certain random
mutations over others and you sort of
force Darwin's hand you put evolution in
one direction versus another it works
very well for instance if we're talking
about bacteria making them better able
to absorb oil spills for instance but
nobody had ever tried this in terms of
attempting to genetically engineer God
so I set up my experiment and saw where
it went I took two different candidate
species to species that were based on
the best source material that i could
find the bible for instance and various
other religious tracts that on the one
hand tell us that God came first on the
other hand that told us that God created
man in His image so it seemed that I
should look to the earliest extant
species which are cyanobacteria on the
one hand and I should look to humans on
the other well humans are very difficult
to work with in a laboratory over
multiple generations so i worked with
essentially a surrogate that was more or
less the same when you look at the holes
the whole phylogenetic tree which are
fruit flies so over the course of seven
days and nights a standard biblical
period of time i use continuous in vitro
evolution in which my
environmental pressure was prayer I
figured that since people are always
praying to God maybe there's some way in
which God metabolizes worshiped so I
took leading prayers for each of the
major monotheistic religions and as a
control group I used exclusively talk
radio so over seven days and nights I
ran the experiment and then I looked for
one of the qualities that is often
associated with godliness as a way of
measuring these two different species
against each other in terms of their
incipient godliness that is that God is
supposed to be omnipresent which
essentially sounds to me like rampant
population growth so I did population
growth studies on both sigh ana bacteria
and fruit flies statistically adjusted
according to their replication rate and
various other factors in order to keep
this absolutely scientifically on the
up-and-up and finally was able to
publish my research in which I
discovered according to these two very
preliminary pilot studies that God is
more closely related baile genetically
speaking to bacteria than to us this is
just the basis of course for many future
experiments that I hope others will
undertake having read this research and
having figured out far better or
certainly different methodologies for
pursuing this sort of question science
and religion are considered by many
especially those are our adherence of
one or the other to be incompatible
systems systems that are irreconcilable
and therefore that those who are on the
other side have to be converted I don't
think that that's necessarily the case
and so I was interested in this project
in this thought experiment in trying to
figure out whether there was a way in
which these incompatible systems could
coexist in a way that they could each
inform the other and could result in a
broader understanding perhaps one that
was more tolerant certainly one that was
more encompassing
of beliefs that come over vast periods
of time are highly developed and are
essential to the way in which our world
works so I looked to both science and
religion for certain core qualities
religion tells us certain things about
the nature of the universe science tells
us certain ways to explore the universe
so what happens if we take the
scientific method and we apply it to the
religious realm that tells us certain
baseline facts we end up I think in an
interesting place one in which the
scientific method doesn't any longer
seem to be so absolutely
all-encompassing that is to say that
perhaps science can be a little bit less
arrogant on the other hand I think that
religion is shown through a process such
as this to maybe take a little bit too
much on faith is there a way in which
the received wisdom of religion cannot
be so rapidly and so uncritically
received so I'm not interested in
converting anyone from one system to
another but rather in finding a way in
which each system by way of delving into
the other and learning from the other
can become a better stronger system a
more satisfying a satisfactory one and
one also that is capable of coexisting
with the other in a way that is at peace
because we're never going to convert
everyone if we haven't already from
science to a religion or vice versa so
we need to find ways in which these
systems can communicate with each other
with due respect for what makes each
system its own the god project is
attempt at achieving that by no means
perfect but I think more broadly
suggestive of a way in which any two or
three or potentially more systems can
potentially be brought into some sort of
tentative alignment and also can be
strengthened through that process you
can't get through life even through the
day without coming upon incompatible
systems simply is the way of the world
when the world become as complex as ours
is that systems are not worked out to
work together there often is a lot of
thought that goes into each system but
they don't naturally communicate because
they probably come from different places
and they serve different purposes yet
you need to be able to negotiate all of
this in terms of trying to resolve some
sort of a personal problem or in terms
of trying to take on some new venture in
the workplace these systems are in place
and they can't be changed they can't be
supplanted but have to be worked with so
I think that as I try to do in the case
of the god project I think that you can
take systems for what they are and you
can find ways in which on the surface
they are incompatible and you can put
them together and try out combinations
until you find some way that doesn't
necessarily make them consistent with
each other but at least find some sort
of a common ground some sort of a piece
that can be reached where each one of
them can be true to itself and is not
threatened and yet both of them or all
of them can work together in a way that
symbiotically in a way that collectively
they lead to something that is stronger
for you
and is more broadly applicable to
everybody else